william barr got the job as america's
top law enforcement officer because he
was loyal to donald trump
now the president might be questioning
that loyalty just hours before a routine
meeting at the white house
the u.s attorney general told the
associated press
he couldn't back up the president's
claims of widespread voter fraud
in 2020 saying we've not seen fraud on a
scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election
william barr became attorney general
after jeff sessions was sacked
donald trump didn't think he was loyal
enough during the early days of the
investigation
into alleged russian interference in the
2016 election
since he took over var has often been
accused of acting more as trump's top
lawyer rather than americans
his department of justice got involved
in cases involving trump allies
it dropped charges against former
national security adviser michael flynn
even though he admitted lying to fbi
agents
and it intervened in the sentencing of
close trump ally
roger stone attorney general barr
also announced the findings of the
mueller probe into russia interference
but was accused of misrepresenting the
final results to make his boss look
better
investigation did not establish that
members of the trump campaign conspired
or coordinated
with the russian government in its
election interference
activities i am sure that all americans
share
my concern about the efforts of the
russian government to interfere in our
presidential
election a concern aired by robert
mueller himself
but there was a growing rift between the
white house and the department of
justice
donald trump wanted a pre-election
investigation into barack obama and joe
biden
and their roles in the russia probe an
fbi announcement
into hillary clinton's emails weeks
before the 2016 election gave him a
boost
he was hoping it would be the same again
barr had nothing to work with
and couldn't deliver just weeks ago the
man in charge of election cyber security
said the 2020 presidential
was the most secure in america's history
that angered the president who claims
without evidence
that the election was stolen from him so
he fired his official
when news of barr's comments hit capitol
hill others suspected
what might be coming in response to
attorney general bill barr i guess he's
the next one to be fired
since he now too says there's no fraud
trump's legal team says there's been no
substantial department of justice
investigation
into any allegations of voter fraud
they've uncovered
they say they have substantial evidence
of wrongdoing in six
states evidence they've yet to make
public or present
in court alan fisher al-jazeera at the
white house